[Música]
Hola a todos y bienvenidos a esta
edición especial de África siete días
dedicamos Este programa a una iniciativa
artística sin precedentes una adaptación
novedosa de la Flauta Mágica la famosa
ópera de Mozart aquí en Colombia y en
colaboración especial con el cantante
lírico congolenio searchy
[Música]
[Aplausos]
se trata de una propuesta original la
fundación kitambo que trabaja para
acercar África y América Latina a través
del arte Tuvo una idea tan Audaz como
ambiciosa poner en escena una versión
innovadora e intercultural de la flauta
mágica de Mozart es aquí en el teatro
Colón el más prestigioso de la capital
colombiana donde los las funciones
tienen lugar a continuación les
presentamos la propuesta y algunos de
sus protagonistas
[Música]
[Aplausos]
la flauta mágica
está ópera austriaca escrita por Mozart
en 1791 cuenta las aventuras del
príncipe tamino que viaja con una flauta
mágica al reino de sarastro para
rescatar a pamina hija de la reina de la
noche
[Música]
la fundación Colombo belgo congoleña
kitambo ofrece una versión original de
esta pieza con ritmo colombiano e
influencia africana para ello reunió a
solistas colombianos y venezolanos
bailarines afrodescendientes de la
compañía afrocolombiana sancofa Marín
veros y un profesor de canto de la
República democrática del Congo el
contra tenor Sears kakuji
como
la compañía de los artistas porque había
que trabajar con ellos y teníamos que
saber qué tipo de voz teníamos y guiar a
los cantantes que habíamos elegido
después del casting Así que hice clases
magistrales fue su coach de técnica
vocal
las iniciativas llevadas a cabo a través
de las artes plásticas y la literatura
la fundación continúa su propósito de
acercar a África y América Latina a
través del arte esta vez el medio
elegido es la música más concretamente
la ópera
[Aplausos]
Aunque este género musical este
Generalmente considerado como elitista e
inasequible para muchos Entonces por qué
la elección de la Flauta Mágica porque
creo que Mozart es muy africano hay
cosas que aparecen en el diálogo y a
través de la adaptación de su obra y nos
preguntamos cómo es posible que todo
suceda por sí solo bueno es porque
Mozart era muy africano en su toque en
su complicidad pero también en su
complejidad musical cuando Oyes a Mozart
sabes enseguida que es él es lo mismo
para la música africana la reconoces
cuando la oyes no se puede confundir con
este proyecto a la fundación también da
una oportunidad a talentos colombianos
con formación en la ópera como la joven
cantante Carol leyton
descubierto muchas cosas en mi voz y
aparte pues he podido aprender de los
talleres de los maestros de mis
compañeros entonces para mí ha sido una
experiencia súper bella la flauta mágica
de Mozart en Colombia en colaboración
con la República democrática del Congo
es otro proyecto ambicioso de la
fundación cuyo objetivo es llevar a cabo
procesos multidisciplinarios de
cocreación y conexión entre las culturas
y las disciplinas para la próxima etapa
quitambo espera exportar la obra a otras
ciudades colombianas Y por qué no ambos
continentes
la Génesis de esta iniciativa parte de
una convicción la importancia del arte
como vía para abrir Mentes y superar
estereotipos tuvimos la oportunidad de
hablar con kathgindunga y Marlin Palmas
las fundadoras digitambo sobre el origen
y el significado de esta
aventuran Bienvenidos a siete días
Gracias por estar con nosotros Entonces
yo quisiera saber Cómo surgió toda esta
aventura en la fundación quitambo
la aventura gracias a mal por este
tiempo con nosotras surge de una
producción que hicimos en el Congo el
año pasado con la cantante lírica Isabel
cavatu realizamos una adaptación de la
flauta mágica
nació todas las ganas de poder hacerlo
en Colombia donde vivimos y cuál es el
objetivo de la fundación quitambo con
este proyecto con un proyecto tan
ambicioso Qué mensaje quiere transmitir
la fundación
le quitamos nació justamente con ese
objetivo de poder acercar talentos de
países africanos a sus raíces aquí a sus
padres aquí en Colombia justamente
Colombia es un país con una diversidad
enorme impresionante que queremos
siempre mostrar a través de nuestros
proyectos de esta obra también
involucramos
instrumentos músicos de las regiones de
Pacífico del Caribe
introducimos también una un cuerpo de
baile sanka de Medellín la que es muy
importante tenemos otros elementos
Tenemos también un artista de Padilla
cauca que va a ser toda la utilería
también
de la bueno y hay mucho más talentos de
las regiones que Y eso es lo que
queremos queremos Mostrar con esta obra
que se puede convivir que se puede
colaborar que se puede crear con con y
mostrando con toda esa diversidad no que
existe aquí y que exista a nivel
nacional bueno internacionales
y cuál fue el reto más grande para
ustedes en todo este proyecto el desafío
más grande pues ir hasta las regiones
eso implica
mucha logística y de las regiones luego
en segundo tiempo invitar a las personas
seleccionadas a Bogotá y introducir unas
telas
en una ópera
y también a nivel musical lograr que la
Marimba y a la percusión estén Al mismo
nivel
que las los instrumentos clásicos de la
orquesta por qué fue importante esto que
la Marimba
estuviese Al mismo nivel que resto
Porque lo que queremos Mostrar es un
gran respeto un mensaje de Gran respeto
por la diferencia y que esta
multiculturalidad que nos caracteriza es
en realidad una gran riqueza Entonces es
muy importante que todo lo que sumamos
en esta adaptación sea con el mayor
respeto y mostrando que enriquece y
aporta más entonces para un mayor
diálogo y intercambio entre África y
Colombia la fundación quitan voy a ha
trabajado ha puesto en marcha varios
proyectos artísticos especialmente a
través de la fotografía ahora la música
y ustedes a través de estas experiencias
han podido comprobar que el arte es la
mejor manera realmente de
de digamos de romper las barreras entre
las culturas nos conectamos desde las
emociones Entonces desde las emociones
Somos todos verdaderos somos enteros
somos reales
Sí y comprobar comprobar es difícil pero
por lo menos tenemos esta convicción que
se puede a través del arte transformar
que se puede unir que se pueden sí es el
arte son emociones es aquí con emociones
logras y no se necesita tanto como
cicatriar un discurso pero es esto une
une porque
las emociones están por todas partes
Entonces si no es que comprobar es
difícil pero sí que pero sí que estamos
convencidas es a través del arte es
nuestro aporte Bueno hay mucho más
caminos evidentemente pero nosotros lo
hacemos a través del arte y pensamos que
si esto funciona y es una buena forma de
mostrar que tenemos mucho más
similitudes que diferencias también
absolutamente y cuáles son las próximas
ambiciones de la fundación bueno primero
con este proyecto que viaje a otras
ciudades del país esperamos volver a las
ciudades donde hicimos las ediciones y
los talleres eso es muy importante para
nosotros
Cali Medellín Cartagena y luego afuera
de las fronteras pensamos que en África
encantado de trabajar con muchos
artistas y músicos en Colombia la
reapertura de esta adaptación
la interpreta
por dos músicos
caleños
Muchas gracias por estas respuestas Y
por haber estado con nosotros en África
7 días Gracias amada por este espacio
Muchas gracias
un vestuario confeccionado con telas
africanas objetos de utilería hechos
según el arte del tejido afrocolombiano
heredado del saber africano una
escenografía afro futurista esta
adaptación única de la Flauta Mágica es
También la historia de mundos diferentes
que se encuentran al menos una docena de
oficios artesanales participaron en la
aventura no se trató solo de crear un
diálogo entre culturas sino también
entre disciplinas así la producción de
esta ópera fue una oportunidad para
desplegar varios Campos artísticos en
torno a un mismo lenguaje musical
universal
la diseñadora Lía Samanta y las
costureras Carolina Loaiza y Carolina
Herrera que juntas diseñaron y crearon
el vestuario de la obra nos hablaron de
su enfoque Durante este proceso de
creación siempre
invitar a Mozart a Colombia de cómo
sería invitarla a Colombia o sin Mozart
tuviera nacido en Colombia Si hubiera
nacido nuestras comunidades indígenas
hubiera nacido entre nuestras
comunidades afro Cómo se comunicaría qué
haría con una marimba qué haría con
nuestro entorno De qué manera se
inspiraría dónde vienen estas telas del
Congo se trajeron directamente el Congo
se hizo una selección de tonos también
una selección digamos de los estampados
todo Digamos que cada estampado tiene un
significado en la cultura africana El
proyecto también ha puesto de relieve a
las competencias y los conocimientos de
los artesanos de los territorios
afrocolombianos escuchemos a Diego
balanta el artista que diseñó los
objetos de utilería de la obra
mi trabajo como artista plástico pues
parte de la investigación que he venido
realizando sobre la práctica del tejido
afro en Padilla cauca entonces Entonces
es rescatar a través de las artes
plásticas esas costumbres esos tejidos
así termina nuestro programa especial
Espero que lo hayan disfrutado Muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros la
actualidad sigue en France 24 y France
24.com